uh i looked on the uh the instagram and
saw that you recently got a cat
i did i'm obsessed with her it's quite
it's unhealthy
as someone who also has a cat um how
hard is it
all day to not be posting pictures of
the cat on
instagram it's pretty hard yeah no i
take a lot of photos and i'm like
no they don't want to see another
picture of my cat so i just
admire them at home although i just
posted a picture of her on twitter
just like a second ago sorry right
i'm telling you it's very difficult um
stupid question but i'm gonna ask it
anyway
if vin diesel was a car what kind of car
would he be
i don't know his car that he he drives i
mean i feel like that really suits him
so it's almost like it's an extension of
dom's personality so i don't know what
his
car is what's his car i don't i don't
remember the name of the car either
don't worry
i'm so sorry no i think
listen i love learning about behind the
scenes of the making of a movie so
is there anything that you think might
surprise people to learn
about the making of a fast and furious
film
um i don't know if this is particularly
surprising but
i think a lot of the time people think
that we
are you know a part of these really big
stunt
sequences when actually like there's a
whole other unit of um
stunt drivers and coordinators and a
whole other unit
in a location shooting the the actual
kind of
driving and crashes and explosions i
mean sometimes we are involved in those
bits but like usually
our kind of uh filming in those
sequences
are usually in a much safer environment
where we're static
and they create the movement of the car
with green screens and stuff and then
they
they kind of cgi us into the main uh
the actual location so i think some
people think
that that you know we are there when
we're not
a lot of the time but some of the time
we might be
i completely um before i run out of time
uh i
am really excited about the uh army of
the dead prequel film that you're a part
of
um can you sort of tease what the film
like can you sort of tease it and what
are you excited for people to see
ah to be honest i'm so terrified to say
anything about that because i've
actually not been told what i can and
can't say
um but obviously it's a prequel to army
of the dead and it's an origin story for
um uh dieter uh matthias is uh
schwei hoffer's uh character and he is
um directing and starring in it
and i think the title kind of gives a
little bit away about what this movie is
about
um and knowing what knowing what
dieter does as a profession
um i think that it that it kind of
will can give a couple of clues um
but i definitely uh i'm terrified to say
any more just in case
i give away anything i completely get it
congrats on this and uh have a good time
with the rest of the speed dating
oh thank you